>>> IN OUR POLITICS LEAD IN THE
WEE HOURS OF THE MORNING
CONGRESSIONAL LEADERS UNVEILED
THE MASSIVE 1.7 TRILLION,
TRILLION GOVERNMENT FUNDING
BILL, BUT WITH THE SHUTDOWN
LOOMING THIS FRIDAY, THE
LAWMAKERS HAVE VERY LITTLE TIME
TO REVIEW THE TEXT WHICH IS
RUNNING MORE THAN 4,000 PAGES
LONG, AND LET'S BRING IN THE
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR JOE MANCHIN A
MEMBER OF THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE.
SENATOR, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
US.
I WANTED ASK YOU, BECAUSE ONE OF
THE THINGS LEFT OUT OF THE
SPENDING BILL ARE TWO WIDELY
SUPPORTED BIPARTISAN ANTI-TRUST
BILLS REINING IN TWO BIG TECH
MONOPOLIES LIKE AMAZON AND
GOOGLE, AND NEITHER WENT TO THE
FLOOR FOR A VOTE, AND I WILL
POINT OUT THAT ONE OF THE
LARGEST FUNDERS FOR CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS IS BIG TECH.
AND SO CAN YOU TELL US ABOUT ANY
EXCUSES?
>> I CANNOT GIVE YOU ONE, AND
FROM SECTION 230 ON DOWN, I
CANNOT GIVE YOU A CLUE
WHATSOEVER.
I CANNOT GIVE YOU AN ANSWER ON
THAT.
WE HAVE BEEN WORKING ON THIS FOR
A YEAR, AND SO WE HAD A LOT OF
INPUT OF WHAT IS IF IN THERE AND
GOING THROUGH APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WORKING THROUGH THERE,
AND IN THE END A LOT OF IT IS
COMING TOGETHER, AND WHY SOME
ARE TAKING OUT, AND ALL FOUR HAS
TO WORK TOGETHER, WHETHER IT IS
McCONNELL OR SENATOR SCHUMER OR
WHETHER IT BE NANCY OR KEVIN ON
THE HOUSE SIDE.
>> ONE THING THAT IS IN THE
MASSIVE BILL, AND I KNOW THAT
YOU ARE HAPPY ABOUT IS THE
LEGISLATION TO REFORM THE
ELECTORAL COUNT ACT TO RAISE THE
THRESHOLD NEEDED TO PRESIDENT
THE PRESIDENTIAL ELECTORALS
WHICH IS ONE IN THE HOUSE, AND
ONE IN THE SENATE, AND ARE YOU
SATISFIED THAT THIS IS GOING TO
SATISFY ANY FUTURE ATTEMPTS TO
OVERTURN WHAT HAPPENED.
>> WELL, IT IS GOING TO STOP
WHAT HAPPENED JANUARY 6th, AND
THAT IS THE MAIN CALL.
EVERYONE HAD A DIFFERENT IDEA OF
HOW TO DO THAT, AND SOME WOULD
GO FURTHER, AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT, AND THE HOUSE DID MORE
THAN WHAT THEY SENT OVER, BUT
HAVING TO WORK IN A BIPARTISAN
WAY, AND WORKING IN THE SENATE,
WE CAME UP WITH SOMETHING THAT
TO BE TOTALLY CEREMONIAL SO THAT
A VICE PRESIDENT CAN NEVER BE
CAUGHT IN THAT SITUATION AGAIN,
AND NEXT OFF, ONLY ONE
CONGRESSPERSON OR ONE SENATOR
COULD NOT HOLD UP A COUNTING
PROCESS FOR ONE STATE, AND NOW
IT IS 20% OR 80 CONGRESSPEOPLE
TO SAY THAT WE THINK THAT THE
STATE OF X-Y-Z IS WRONG, AND THE
COUNT IS WRONG, AND WE CONTEST
THAT, AND YOU HAVE TO HAVE 20
OTHER SENATORS TO AGREE WITH
THAT, AND THAT IS ANOTHER
WRINKLE TO ADD OVERSIGHT.
AND ALSO, THE ELECTORAL COLLEGE
HAVE TO BE CHOSEN BEFORE THE
ELECTION, AND NOT AFTER, TO TRY
TO GET PEOPLE TO GO WITH YOU,
AND WE HAVE THE ACCELERATED
COURT PROCEDURES TO STOP WHAT
HAPPENED JANUARY 6th, AND WE
HAVE A LOT TO DO, BUT WE HAVE
STATES RIGHTS ALSO.
>> YES, AND I DON'T KNOW IF YOU
SAW, BUT KEVIN McCARTHY WHO IS
TRYING TO GET THE VOTES TO BE
SPEAKER, AND HE SAID THAT IF ANY
OF THE REPUBLICANS IN THE SENATE
VOTED FOR THIS OMNIBUS BILL,
THEN THEIR LEGISLATIVE
PRIORITIES WILL NOT BE HEARD IN
THE HOUSE WHEN HE IS SPEAKER,
AND MITT ROMNEY CALLED THAT
SILLINESS, AND WHAT IS THAT?
>> I THINK THAT MITT KNOWS IT
PRETTY WELL.
THIS IS NOT A VINDICTIVE TYPE OF
THING THAT WE ARE NOT IN HIGH
SCHOOL OR COLLEGE AND PLAYING
THE GAMES BACK AND FORTH, AND
THIS IS REAL LIFE.
WITH THAT BEING SAID, KEVIN IS
FIGHTING FOR HIS POLITICAL LIFE
OVER THERE, AND WISH HIM WELL.
WE HAVE NO IDEA HOW IT IS GOING
TO TURN OUT, BUT TO SAY THAT YOU
WILL STOP IT, AND HOLD IT
HOSTAGE IF WE DO THINGS THAT ARE
BEST FOR OUR COUNTRY ON THAT
SIDE, AND WE HAVE DEMOCRATS AND
THE OTHER SIDE, WHICH IS WHY WE
HAVE A BI-CAMERAL SIDE.
SO TO SAY THAT ONE IS IN CONTROL
AND THE OTHER IS NOT, AND IT IS
GOING TO BE DEAD, THAT IS NOT
LEADERSHIP.
>> AND ANOTHER PART OF THE
OMNIBUS BILL LEFT OUT IS TO
SUPPORT THE TROOPS THAT
SUPPORTED THE AFGHAN TROOPS.
WOULD YOU SUPPORT IT?
>> YES, AND THERE WERE PEOPLE
RISKING THEIR LIVES AND PROMISES
MADE.
WHEN WE GO INTO AREAS OF
CONFLICT, AND WHEN WE HAVE OUR
TROOPS, AND THE LIVES OF OUR
TROOPS IN DANGER, AND WHEN WE
HAVE PEOPLE WHO ARE TRYING TO
WORK WITH US TO GIVE US THE BEST
CHANCE OF SUCCESS, AND WE CAN AT
LEAST MAKE SURE THAT WE KEEP
THEM PROTECTED, YES.
>> AND NOW, CONGRESS HAS FAILED
TO DEAL THE BORDER FOR DECADES
AS I DON'T HAVE TO TELL YOU, BUT
ANY BIPARTISAN EFFORT TO SOLVE
THIS, AND WHY HASN'T THERE BEEN
ANY EFFORT TO SOLVE THIS?
>> I BELIEVE THERE HAS, AND I
BELIEVE THERE IS A LOT GOING ON,
AND THE ADMINISTRATION OF
SENATOR MAYORKAS HAS BEEN
TALKING WITH SEVERAL THINGS THAT
HAVE BEEN PUTTING TOGETHER, AND
JOHN KORNAN AND MYSELF PUTTING
IT TOGETHER, AND CONGRESSMAN
QUAYAR AND CORNYN IN TEXAS, THEY
BELIEVE THAT THERE ARE THINGS
THAT CAN BE DONE, AND EXCHANGING
THE IDEAS BACK AND FORTH, AND WE
HAVE WRITTEN, A LETTER OF WHICH
42 MUST BE INFORCED AND NOT ONLY
IN THE REALM OF SECURITY, BUT
STWROE SECURE OUR BORDERS.
THERE IS NEVER GOING TO BE
MEANINGFUL IMMIGRATION REFORM
UNTIL WE GET COMMITTED TO
SECURING OUR BORDER.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE A SECURE
BORDER.
THERE HAS TO BE POINTS OF ENTRY,
AND YOU HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
THE PEOPLE GO THROUGH THE PROPER
VETTING PROCESS.
THOSE ARE THINGS THAT YOU CAN
DO, AND UNTIL GROW AND WHAT TO
SECURE -- IT IS GOING TO TAKE
EVERYTHING.
AT THE 2010 BILL IS THE BEST
PIECE OF LEGISLATION ON
IMMIGRATION, AND WE COULD NOT
GET A VOTE IN THE HOUSE AT THAT
TIME, AND IT IS A SHAME THAT IT
NEVER HAPPENED, BECAUSE WE
PASSED IT BIPARTISAN OVER 68
VOTES IN THE SENATE.
>> YEAH.
>> IT IS BASICALLY GEARED AROUND
THAT YOU COULD NOT HAVE ANYBODY
BECOMING A U.S. CITIZEN, UNTIL
BORDER WAS DEEMED SECURE.
>> YEAH, AFTER ARIZONA SENATOR
KYRSTEN SINEMA ANNOUNCED SHEED
WAS LEAVING THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY, HAVE YOU DECIDED WHAT YOU
WANT TO DO?
>> WELL, JAKE, I DON'T THINK
THAT ANYBODY IS MORE INDEPENDENT
THAN ME, AND THE WAVY BEEN
VOTING OVER THE LAST 40 YEARS OF
MY LIFE.
I HAVE A NUMBER OF FRIENDS WHO
ARE ON BOTH SIDES OF THE ISLE.
I LIKE KIRSTEN, AND SHE IS VERY
ARTICULATE OF WHY SHE MADE THE
DECISION OF WHAT SHE DID.
SO I WILL MAKE A DECISION IF I
WANT TO, AND THE FACT IS THAT I
WILL NOT CHANGE A VOTE UNLESS I
CANNOT EXPLAIN IT.
I WILL NOT SUPPORT SOMETHING
THAT MAKE NOS SENSE TO THE
DEMOCRATS OR THE REPUBLICANS.
AND PEOPLE HAVE GOTTEN SO --
WHAT TEAM ARE YOU ON?
I AM ON ONE TEAM, THE AMERICAN
TEAM.
I WOULD LIKE TO THINK THAT WE
ARE ALL ON THE SAME SIDE, BUT WE
HAVE DIFFERE